so like if my leg got blown off I look
at my leg with your mind's eye five five
one five six it's not working it's five
five one five five five one five five
five five five five five
accidents
the dollar dude
it's the wrong number
[Music]
everybody take this with a grain of salt
I I don't know if I fully believe it at
all but um it is fun and interesting on
Tick Tock apparently it's been going
around and a couple people I've been
pulling some ciad classified information
oh yeah yeah yo they Declassified a ton
of stuff like some JFK [__] no this has
nothing to do with anything you guys
probably think it has to do with
Epstein but uh it's a piece of paper
that shows a particular type of
information called daily tools it's a
Declassified CIA document that talks
about daily tools for example to go into
normal natural restful sleep there's
like instructions uh to remember there's
instructions to reduce pain signals
there's instructions that's time one of
the more viral ones I went on Tick Tock
recently and again this sounds crazy all
right to reduce pain signals okay
look with your closed eyes at that part
of your body
which is the source of pain signals as
you look repeat in your mind the number
55515 when you do these two things the
pain signals will slowly reduce until
they are no longer important
so like if
if blown off
with your mind's eye five five one five
six it's not working it's five five one
five five five one five five five five
five five
it's the wrong number you know like it
says to look at it what if the Pain's in
your butthole and you can't look it's
with your mind's eye your eyes so it
says close your eyes and look with your
mind's eye basically and then you
imagine and basically see that spot and
then you say these numbers and chant
them until you no longer feel pain does
it say this is a CIA that's a CIA
document does it say the significance of
the 55515 no you're probably calling
your cell Department to go and [__]
work on the customer service part of
your body kind of I bet you because we
have we all have Nanobots inside of us
that we've been eating for decades
that's probably what it does five five
five one five five goes it's like oh
pain and it just goes to the pain area I
like the nonchalant yeah we've been
eating Nanobots for decades it was like
some Matrix stuff you guys didn't know
that yeah
dude that's that is kind of tight though
like right you didn't have that so I
wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised eyes
though because like most military and
paramilitary Protocols are broken down
by the numbers like that so like for
anything like whether to sharpen the
knife there's a whole manual how to do
it specifically so everyone does it the
same how to clean a rifle and even like
how to shoot it's the exact same way and
they call this like the warrior stance
so even
um like the warrior stance is the
fundamental from a basic Soldier all the
way to an AV seal where like this is
fighting stance and then also the way
you present the a weapon is the same way
as you would protect the face so that
way they can almost program like every
single scenario so it's easy to teach
and expand upon so this could be a way
to really like okay if you're not under
hostage this is the situation that you
do this and then if this happens the 555
goes to whatever and it goes to and it
keeps scaling that's [__] those like
so you're using an identifier code it
could be it could be yeah because that's
how the that's how they write manuals in
the military like everything is to the T
because it has to work on everything in
every situation basically you're saying
it won't work for us but it'll work for
you no it worked for everybody yeah or
if you weren't in the military yeah
because we're not in the military no no
I work for everybody but we don't know
what the
555-155 is not that many fives but yeah
I don't know either so like for example
to go to go into normal natural restful
sleep right uh lie down in a comfortable
position breathe deeply five times and
count from one to twenty before you
reach the count of 20 you will go into a
normal wrestle counting sheep dude yeah
I've not got before 20. that's to
remember that's a [__] remember any
part of your life experience
I kind of tried to do this yesterday it
didn't work to remember any part of your
life experience close your eyes and
touch softly the fingers of your right
hand to the center of your forehead when
you do this you recall and remember
immediately that which you consciously
desire
dude her name wasn't Eunice it was
Janice
what did you guys see I saw a shrimp
tempura
that's on brand for Joe is that that's
what he wants that's what he wants right
now that what she desires shrimp tempura
dude is that you're supposed to
pronounce it tempura
like that you gotta make it longer
you guys ever listen to Andrew
huberman's podcast yeah I've been
listening to him I like them he's really
good because he he actually he's like a
neuroscientist or whatever the [__] man
biologists he's a PhD just never
but he's really
really found these Protocols of like
manuals of how to get restful sleep or
how to maybe remember something but he's
able to explain the mechanisms through a
science lens that's easy for dummies
like me to understand but not really but
he has like he could explain all that
stuff and it's kind of like adjacent to
the stuff that he talks about it's
pretty cool like for something like that
where you like you breathe or whatever
and breathe deeply count to five like
he'll explain how the like increased
oxygen levels triggers some sort of like
a transmitter in your body to decrease
your sympathetic nervous system or bring
your heart rate like [__] like that
you don't know what the [__] he's
talking about yeah but after you you
listen you're like oh I think I know how
it works now because you can explain the
mechanism but you could tell he's a
professor because of the way he talks
it's like oh you know he teaches
dumbasses all day yeah bro for sure he
okay there's just one thing that he does
it's called nsdr I don't it's like
non-deep restful sleep or some [__] I
don't know it doesn't even add up to
that yeah dude whatever hey whatever
dude but anyways you could look it up
and like sometimes what he'll like
recommend is if you are like really
tired of the middle of the day you put
this uh you just close your eyes and
kind of rest and you put headphones on
you listen to the him like repeating
these like yoga cues or whatever he has
a good voice too it's great voice dude
and then he'll he'll kind of guide you
through
just the mindfulness of like deep rest
for like 10 minutes and you wake up and
you're like holy [__] yeah I actually
feel rested I did it like I've done it
like four or five times throughout the
day oh yeah I've done similar stuff like
that there's this company uh called
brain tap that puts this giant [__] it's
like a VR system ad dude no I swear to
God what was that we're in an ad now and
don't get free probable hey no free
promo dude take that back bleep that can
but same thing it's like uh it it like
you put it over your eyes and then it
just and there's an audio thing that
kind of talks yeah it talks it doesn't
like Chan anything it like literally
talks it just guides you through yeah
it's great it's kind of like meditation
but it's like you he'll say things like
you know think about your hands and then
your arms and like it's just weird is
that like lightweight Placebo is that
like you're like putting yourself in
that like intentional space anyway
therefore you like I think everything
comes from breathing and deep breathing
yeah at the end of the day like for you
to relax yourself for you to recover for
you to feel better it all comes from
like nasal breasts and just really
focusing on your breath and just getting
more oxygen into your the rest of your
body so I think that's probably most of
it but then just the mindfulness of
taking 10 minutes out of your day to
recover is actually pretty tight what
was that guy's name Andrew huberman I
see I think Andrew huberman has the
original manual for the the Nanobots in
our bodies that's what it is it's a
nanobot triggers all that he knows he
knows he put it in our bodies yeah
that's why the government's always known
where we are
like the 40s and 50s oh how are they
getting the Nanobots in our body food
like McDonald's so like oh [__] yeah I
got too many animals because you know
Monsanto they genetically modify the
food yeah yeah what that means is they
just put Nanobots in the food [__]
Monsanto dude there's an ad for what
about that diarrhea it doesn't come out
uh some do some do but this a lot of
them stay too but you gotta eat again
though
you know what I mean you're replenished
but you're constantly getting the salsa
Roja or you're constantly [__] in your
brain look at the diarrhea is on this
guy's mouth
yeah the batteries don't last longer
than the nettlebots so that you we flush
them out we get new ones in oh and then
that's why we can trigger the five five
one one but do the Nanobots fight if
they're from different governments
because like if I go to 99 Ranch I'm
pretty sure I'm getting Chinese Nanobots
and if I go to H Mart I got Korean
national box and if I go to Nigeria
market like dude it's world war three up
in here dude 99 Ranch government is
crazy that's what food poisoning is
that's what food oh it's a conflict of
natural yeah yeah you get diarrhea yeah
yeah are you currently experiencing food
conflict not at all at all left oh good
it's peace it's a piece zone now what
that's why you get back to Switzerland
that's why they don't like it when you
combine Whole Foods and um the
supermarket the the Mexican supermarket
they get like no we don't like that two
different governments two different
governments yeah what other protocols do
they have in their [__] thing in the
[__] thing
to reduce emotional charge close your
eyes inhale deeply hold breath for a
moment then think of the calming
cleansing color green when you do this
exhale slowly and the green energy will
push all excess and harmful emotional
charge this is all Placebo [__] it's
like if
green I [__] it emotional trauma gone
well I have a question though so
emotional charge I'm assuming includes
like you're upset at someone so let's
say like you're in a fight with someone
he's ready to pounce do you have to
close your eyes because I feel like
right when you close your eyes you get
[__] up no he's doing it too so you'll
oh that's right that's right neglected
that I will say on that one this
probably is not correlated but I
remember when uh anytime we'd be like
super drunk or super high or something
like that and in a car and getting like
car sick right
um one of my homies one time was like
roll down the window and look at just
the trees look at just green right and
then all right cool and I look at green
and that'll literally make me feel
better that's just yeah yeah yeah is
that the mushrooms talking or or like
right they always try to look at
something further away that's not like
the ground that's not moving as far yeah
yeah and then you kind of like oh I
gotta feel a little bit better I think
that's true though I think that works
that's good I do that too because
sometimes I'm at Walmart and there's too
many ugly people and I go oh [__] and I
have to look at it I gotta look at
Instagram and then there's a there's
someone beautiful on Instagram and I'm
like
that's what you gotta do it's a palette
cleanser is what they call it
[Music]
foreign